breathing's from podcast Ville the
Church of what's happened now is brought
to you by hims let me ask you something
is that hairline slowly starting to move
backwards you see any bald spots yet how
will you feel a year from now when it's
business as usual up there when you
don't have that much hair let me ask you
another question you ever go out with
your little girlfriend then you come
home and the bottom part of your body
ain't working correctly yeah that about
to do well guess what Uncle Joe is here
to help all that stuff for him tom is a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
and sexual wellness for men are you
kidding me or what hymns connect you
with real doctors and medical grade
solutions to treat hair loss with
well-known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescriptions to help you
keep your hair and also help you on that
date if you know what I'm talking about
so do me a favor right I'm gonna take
care of you right now because there's no
waiting room there's no wall awkward
person the doctor visit nothing all you
got to do is go to for hims com what I'm
gonna do for the church family is this
I'm gonna give you a trial month of
hymns for five hours Joey what are you
talking I'm gonna give you a trial month
of hymns for five hours whether it's
hair loss or sexual wellness five hours
right now while supplies last see the
website for full details this would cost
you hundreds if you went to a doctor or
pharmacy but uncle Joey is coming
through for you go to for hims comm
slash Joey that's for hims fo r hims
dot-com slash Joey alright right now
while supplies last the church is also
sponsored by one of my favorites my
bookie cuz you know what's going on this
weekend everybody's asking who's gonna
win the big [ __ ] game is it Brady
is it balichek is it another
championship for the Patriots dynasty
what's the over-and-under what am i
Johnnie Houdini let me tell you what
you're gonna do you're gonna go to my
book everything business for years and
their reputation is rock-solid you
understand me my boogie has become the
premier destination for prop bets also
these guys truly let you bet on anything
but listen it's
right now right now while we're talking
go to my bookie and they're gonna match
your deposit with the 50% bonus all
right use promo code Church to activate
the offer
listen my bookie you win they pay it's
that simple
take that [ __ ] mule Lee Bruce Buffer
Joey Diaz [ __ ] king of poker I'm you
won around this you know what [ __ ] did
you not get reven Lenny everybody was
around everybody was in rounders but
back when they made rounders that was
really before I took off you know in my
poker world how long have you been
playing poker my dad taught me how to
play poker when I was nine years old he
taught me how to play poker
which back then was five-card draw seven
card stud he taught me how to play
blackjack and he talked about horse
racing and he said son the only way to
follow horse with a shovel don't bet on
him right so I never went I went to the
track couple times had a great time but
I've never been a horse better you
notice when you go to the track with all
respect it's some of the saddest looking
people walking around the track they're
more like a New Jersey yeah yeah it's
crazy so I started playing cash games
with my brother Brian when I was 14 and
during the summertime we play a lot of
caddies from the local country clubs
well I had you know good money and I
started making some money and Brian made
a good amount of money and actually with
the money he made in the poker games
when he was 18 he took himself over to
Europe for for a couple of months you
know and had a good time my dad was
always you know telling us about Street
knowledge you know we we touched on it
earlier but my dad was old breed and
sure your dad was like that just like
your old breed I'm a little bit old
breed raising a kid back then was a lot
different you know now their faces are
in the screens fortnight's causing
issues with families divorces
everybody's on and on it needs to be
managed totally differently and back
then where with all respect the kids are
on the screen it's not getting better
their communication skills they're all
into the technology which is fantastic
but I think it's also causing some
issues I think in ten years you're gonna
have a hard time finding something's
gonna be able walk in a room and close a
deal make a sale you know like a
Salesman right because communication
skills are gonna be tight when you were
a kid and I was a kid and I was riding
my bike to baseball games I was playing
baseball till 5 o'clock I was going down
to five o'clock 5 o'clock well 4 o'clock
yeah we go I was out till 9 meet you ok
talking yeah today you stayed up till
dinner yeah my mom would make me come up
at once time to run civilize just to
slow my heartbeat down between men you
know I'm saying cuz by that time you
already tortured somebody it was a full
day late yeah you know wiffle ball
stickball Johnny ride a pony
ha peas and butter go get your mother no
walk to the corner and shoplift and then
go up and throw eggs at mr. martini and
then [ __ ] Mister Softee would come
and upstairs
eat dinner and then if you did good at
dinner your mom will let you go out of
song as long as you stayed in front of
the house till 9 o'clock
what and you would take chances you know
when she was going to shower so you that
would give you a chance to run around
the corner and my whole thing is like I
used to run across Broadway in New York
City right and I look at my daughter
she's six she'll even run across [ __ ]
here I am running my mother would say
don't cross Broadway yeah and I would
run across Broadway with my friends with
no lights there was no and then no there
was no there was no 10 seconds or but
you know a good time yeah but back then
you know is we live in the world of
stranger danger these days right and
it's like there's no way you can let
your kids run free like that it's it's a
different world and it's a different
time for raising but I thought I'm not
saying that it's bad the way the kids
being raised because we have to adjust
the way technology goes but I think that
they're not as being raised as tough as
we were as kids but even tougher the
generations before me every computer at
the house has a time in your house yeah
yeah for her purposes my purposes and
Hawaii's purpose right my timer is my
back I have an hour to sit and I have to
do something for now I'll have to come
back for now I'm trying to write a book
that's my for my daughter I get her out
there's a rule at the house he's gotta
be out by mind there's don't school I
want her out of there by 9:00 burning
that energy 9:00 in the morning with my
yeah right I'm gonna have her work in
the same way that she's already doing
chores for the mother good she's got a
vacuum and clean and dust and she
I don't know how much more mother you
know there's little things just because
the world's changing doesn't mean I have
to change now just cuz the world change
doesn't mean I'm gonna take a text
message no you could text me - your face
is green
you hate text I won't you don't tax it
up yeah I think even say it on your
answering machine
don't used to leaving a message no more
yeah I don't don't leave him leave him I
don't give a [ __ ] I know the a I know
the numbers if you text me and I don't
know the number you listen if you text
me you got no chance right but if you
text me and I don't know your number you
really got it yeah you got no chance you
got a change you're just gonna burn a
slow death yeah I like people just come
up with a tech and I don't even get the
text I won't get the text I go home they
come up on my iPad uh-huh so unless I
open up my iPad you don't see him I
don't say well you know it's like even
in the dating world right like if your
data if you date a girl who's under the
age of 35
I'd say 30 35 used to be that dating was
I love the phone calls
I love conversing on the phone it's the
greatest form of mental foreplay there
is before you pick up your date I mean
yeah I'm interested in you maybe you
know romancing him getting excited about
the date I I can't get that across and
tennis no I can't do that and I love the
whole setup of it I mean honestly I
don't have that many I sit down talk for
an hour on the phone have a leave you
saying this the other night sir I worked
Brad just last week yeah Thursday took
leave with me but yeah a night I drove
by myself before I do a show I enjoy
myself
right before I do a show I like driving
and no radio yeah just digging into the
coping hit into your son even thinking
about jokes I'm thinking about parts of
my life
mm-hmm sad things how I had that
argument Bruce before death in 1984 we
still don't talk right I think about all
that [ __ ] right you know and on the way
back I was into the radio and on the way
back that song came by my Michael
Jackson remember the time mm-hmm and I
was listening to the lyrics and he goes
we'd be talking on the phone all night I
said to myself do people still do kids
still I still remember I still remember
the girl's name but I would talk to
from midnight to 6:00 in the morning
yeah Epson go to the seventh grade yeah
brother just hit me up yeah there's an
actor in New York
I mean this girl would talk long I never
[ __ ] me if you want the why never even
suck the titties right that's what she
did back then right you talked for five
rides on the phone right that the other
night one of these nights came on by the
Eagles mm-hmm that was my song with this
girl from Miami Grace on the Tosh and
Rebecca they were twins and then I was
like 10 when that song came out 75 I was
12 and then I remembered I started my
first long-distance relationship and I
didn't know about long-distance mm-hmm
I'm picking up the phone dialing 305
eight times a day yep in 1975 yep one
day my mother came up with 24 pages of
phone bills Oh through all that being
said how you expecting to pay for this
bill it was like an $800 phone bill I
used to have I had to give a four out of
my bank account and work out for weeks
for ten I would work at the bar and we
worked I would get like 80 a week so she
took 40 a week for 10 weeks yeah until
my Vig was paid we know back in 75 I
mean the cell phones back I graduated
high school in 75 she's right yeah cuz
I've got four years on you right
four graduated maybe two I'm 61 how old
are you 56 19th I get five years on five
you be nice to your elders yes
so you haha thank you but you know going
back then the telephones back then we're
like Michael Douglas in Wall Street
walking on the beach you know with the
big square things and I remember back
when was the first cell phone it was
that big big size they had one an S and
that's good bar and uh narcos they were
[ __ ] 20 that's what I'm talking about
okay up at your house so an Escobar they
have those what do you call those phones
pear salad from satellite phones yeah
that's what they're using there but this
thing was like big and it used to sit in
the carriage in the middle of the car we
all excited when we got our cell phones
but my friggin cell phone bills back
then yes
worth a thousand plus you were paying
huge amounts of time per minute back
that has changed so much minute you
planned
huge your plan yeah 600 minutes a month
you didn't talk about you those day now
no no real quick hello goodbye I gotta
save our minutes is SHINee there was
someone on your phone where you could
check how many minutes you had for the
month computer page on Sprint we'd show
you how many oh my god
holy [ __ ] and now people like in their
20s and younger they Haley get anxiety
about talking on the phone my bill text
but they don't talk on the phone I think
that social anxiety along with a DD is
rampant these days why do you think
social anxiety is so big that I see it
in a lot of you know what I notice in
kids when I used to walk in a room and
I'd say to my dad even as a young kid my
dad was a Marine drill instructor Korea
in World War two thirteen years and then
Marine Corps probably has Michael my
brother the legendary who you've worked
with who by the way just got inducted
into the International Sports Hall of
Fame days of them yeah he's great in
liberating it's awesome trim so I'd walk
in a room and I say hi dad you go son
project your voice let them know you're
in the room right okay dad alright and
you know son look him in the eye shake
their hands look him in the eye when you
talk to a man look them in the eye B
doesn't look you in the eyes something's
wrong right so I mean kids do that I
notice the kids now they and I and again
I love children you know I helped raise
two boys Henry and Rupert they're about
to be 11 and ones 14 it's a great
experience in my life
helping raise these two boys is their
Godfather their uncle and second father
you know and I put a lot into it but I'm
noticing that kids look down
they don't look you in the eye they
don't communicate they stand across from
each other they're sitting on the couch
like they're doing here and they're not
looking each other and talking they're
texting to each other right it's not
teaching that in no I don't the proper
term is intimacy but just communication
skills you know you walk in to get a job
am I gonna hire you if you walk in my
office looking at the floor not making
eye contact with me not making proper
communication Oh have you ever seen it
with sunglasses on you you ever seen no
I never wait no no no no don't believe
it
where I came from you know it's
Macklemore really
yeah really a town I grew up but we were
sunglasses interesting no earrings note
that to earrings I can understand
nothing yeah nothing well sadly I grew
up in you walk into a room with
sunglasses somebody would smack them off
your face and when did that change what
about right now you go back there now
today after they tattoo Danny rained and
lost our kids I hang up a still straight
straight like Testament Ali was this way
of being that was just it's like the
bottle believed in glass it's like the
Bronx Tale when you come in my house you
take those [ __ ] things off well
unless you're [ __ ] Steve McQueen
uh-huh don't put Steve's [ __ ]
sunglasses on you want to hear a quick
Steve McQueen sunglass story yeah okay
one of the best at one of the best
movies McQueen ever made where he people
think he really a true acting turn cuz
like you know I was good friends with
him really good friends for the last six
years of his life I surfed in front of
his house every day he was my neighbor
quarter mile away from me in Malibu and
he had a great surf spot in front of his
house when he made the Thomas Crown
Affair riot movie which she dressed up
and all he wore these blue lens Persol
glasses sunglasses which they make today
they're the Steve McQueen version they
fold right so his last wife Barbara
mentee auctioned off a bunch of his
materials in it was the sunglasses from
the Thomas Crown Affair they sold for
thirty five thousand dollars okay nobody
knows this but when you walked in his
house he had a little wicker basket by
the front door there were four pair of
those sunglasses in the wicker basket
right so like Chad is his son is one of
my best friends who has auctioned off a
lot of material his jacket from bullet
valued the one on the poster the great
movie bullet valued at $800,000 when an
auction the auction went up to seven
hundred twenty five thousand and so they
didn't sell it because that's the
reserve it had to get eight hundred
thousand well Chad told me that that's
chances are were not the original
sunglasses from no sorry if anybody's
listening to bought this I'm not trying
to make trouble but it was probably not
the original sunglasses his dad had a I
remember myself he had a little wicker
basket right there with all the glasses
now I actually own the poster of the
Thomas Crown Affair which what do you
remember the
yes then they made it they remade it
with Pierce Brosnan who'd great right
good no shake there's a scene in that
movie that that like when Sam Peckinpah
made a movie called the Wild Bunch it
changed the way violence I was Perseus
the amend asleep with the graves movie
one of the 100 greatest movies of all
time a story about men and on or even
those who were criminals but story I can
recite every line from that film I've
seen it over 200 times getting back to
probably lose track of what I'm saying
what was I asked D'Arnot you have the
poster for the Thomas crime yeah the
Thomas Crown Affair so the scene and the
Thomas Crown Affair when he had Faye
Dunaway or playing chess
and if you remember how provocatively
she would touch the chess pieces this
was big stuff back then this was very
risque right then they kissed each other
and the camera went 360 degrees around
them as they kissed with open mouths
kisses that's the first open mouth kiss
ever in Hollywood that's what you know
changed the art of kissing it's one of
the at that time considered what you an
erotic see me look up Thomas Crown
Affair I'm gonna guess when I met
Stephen 74 for the first time he just
got done doing or 73 the getaway just
got done doing the getaway I met him and
now and grow up the 868 I was gonna say
yeah 68 so that's one that changed you
know there's certain there's certain
films whether it's Orson Welles back you
know with one of his original movies
they're trendsetters you know Tarantino
he changes film you know that certain
scene certain films that just change the
way films are made and that had one
little aspect to it but the jacket in
Bullitt the point is trying to make is
I'm going back and forth on subjects
here Steve gave me a jacket that was a
Brooks Brothers jacket Steve gave me a
jacket when I was a kid
same jacket right but it wasn't the one
worn in the movie I wish I kept that
jacket a little certificate of
authenticity I don't know why it being a
big collector of memorabilia that I am
today identity movie posters you name it
but that Jack could probably even though
he didn't wear it a movie to be worth
one hundred fifty two hundred thousand
dollars today the fire suit in the movie
LeMond when we made the yo-yo a month
the car the car curry something the fire
suit he wore underneath his race suit
did auction off for $750,000 the tag
heuer watch that he warned his wrist
also auctioned off for 750 but then he
wore in the towering inferno
I don't read that the Hat that the
fireman's hat Yan wore went for like 600
that I don't quote me no that's what I
remember reading it going
Jesus this had to be 10 years ago before
I even knew you were involved with
McQueen anything's possible
I've seen his stuff going infernal yeah
I had and something else that he did I
remember reading went off big big before
before just came out with this will you
do you take it home put in your closet
they just pay people pay money for crazy
things there was just a lock of hair
Marilyn Monroe's lock of hair a lock of
hair just so for $16,000 $16,000 meant
seen by Jackie Robinson the baseball
player who was the first afro-american
black baseball player to ever be play on
a major league team the original
document is now hawk being up for
auction and it's valued at 36 million
dollars whoa what what document they're
putting it up for auction this girl's
contractor saw his first contract for
his first major league baseball contract
then the movie 52 Jackie Robert yes yes
so her 42 Jackie Robinson
they're starting off 15 million base
they expect the document to sell for 36
million or more I love this stuff I'm a
big collector you know when you go on
the road my whole middle watch that much
TV yeah
going on the road I put the TV on but
I'll put netflix on and put the
earphones up I'm a [ __ ] idiot I'm an
idiot - I did the same thing I'll watch
like an old UFC and watch so I'm
watching or listening and and I do all
that [ __ ] what the [ __ ] were you just
talking about your TV chat you Roberts
recharge a key Robson Steve McQueen
collectibles
I mean improves do you I was gonna ask
what your most expensive thing is but
have you been at an auction where
something went for like three four
million dollars mmm cheese yeah it's
very common
the I have an original poster of the
great movie everybody watches a
Christmas called It's a Wonderful Life
one of my favorite tremendous favorite
movies all Jimmy Stewart Donna Reeve
what I lost what a fox Donna Reed wasn't
her heyday you know it's amazing it's a
7 foot high poster and it's in three
pieces now this the reason I collect a
lot of vintage movie posters because
they're like artwork yeah I love them
look cool yeah my whole house is just
you know and I've got stuff involved
because I have so much of this stuff but
he it's it's a Jimmy Stewart and he's
holding Donna Reed over his head and her
theater in the air and her pearls are
dangling and they're smiling and it's
it's a Wonderful Life right so I paid
like $4,000 for this back in like 1992
and when they used to tear down when the
movies were done running at the movie
theaters there's the one sheet the
single sheet and there's the three
sheets well the three sheets they would
just tear down the one sheets they would
roll up so there's that's why if you got
a three sheet it's a very rare piece so
this piece is probably valuing around 40
50 thousand today or whatever but
Christie's contacted me here's another
big auction house because it's like one
of less than six known so they wanted me
to sell it okay there's no way I'm
selling it if I'm never broke right and
I'm homeless you're gonna see me with
this damn post or underneath my arm
because it means everything to me it
motivates me it's a wonderful life you
know it's what's what we're all
searching for right so movie memorabilia
some of the biggest most expensive
memorabilia I collect a lot of guns and
artifacts all World War two and before I
don't hunt I'm not a hunter not saying
is anything wrong with that if it's done
correctly there's I have issues with it
in many cases but I do collect and I
have a lot of World War two memorabilia
and the most expensive stuff that's
being sold is the German military of
weaponry and artifacts from World War
two it's like some of the most expensive
stuff you'll ever find going up in value
sports cards Oh dopants wax packs
remember we were kid we'd collect them
we'd open up we get the gum we get the
baseball cards all that kind of stuff
right I've got on open wax packs from
the 50s and the 60s I pay a thousand
dollar piece of bubble gum right now
well you'll have to pay a thousand
dollars for my damn pad usually harder
to [ __ ] it was already broken break your
teeth on that's what gave you the jaw
strength you have to
yeah we're chewing on that [ __ ] cheap
bubble cheap bubble gum and jawbreakers
members law breakers like a mother hell
yeah big-time big-time so determines
like I know like a baseball card or like
Bob Lingus sent me a picture of Julius
Erving mm-hmm that's his signature that
has the authorization all that stuff
yeah but who determines the values like
how do you know what like Tony Soprano
the soprano 20th anniversary was on two
weeks on HBO right I watched a couple
episodes and he showed up with JFK's
sailor hat mm-hmm some hat yeah what oh
[ __ ] knows of JFK man you put that on is
this some fat guy in Boston right now
giggling with 80,000 there's a bank
account a room for the Navy hats you
know that's the problem but I had well
unless I know you you're famous Wiens
son
yeah he gave it to me I'm in hard shape
I can't stop doing blow
take this poster right now buy from here
and write happy in 10 years when you get
you get together I'll sell it back to
you if it's a you know but who
determines act is there like a house oh
I know what I was talking about
points what's the pond stars ponds Pawn
Stars let me tell you something I'm not
watching the TV on the road i watch that
show and you got it
I learned like a [ __ ] about
pricing and stuff they're pretty well
they're pretty well set up you know
they're very well set it's scripted and
all to it to a larger but you got Pawn
Stars you've got to antique road show I
only want out stars the Lansing when I
want a Roadhouse erosions oh yeah
probably just died and poor yeah the
father just got just died
but that show you always learn you learn
a lot and to answer your question about
how do you determine the value it's like
how do you determine the value of a
piece of real estate the most common way
is the comps right the house down the
street sold it's this thing comp so once
an item sells I'll give you an example
my UFC 232 cards the Amanda noonas fight
where she fought Cris cyborg right I
only done this 15 times 16 times where I
sold out the cards and I do for animal
military and children's charities I get
partial proceeds in this case was
Wish Foundation so I sold I auctioned
off individual cards instead of the set
all the cards in the John Jones card
sold for around 150 each to 250 for the
John Jones cards roughly the Amana
noonas card so for four thousand two
hundred and seventy two dollars that
piece of karma time we met a buyers got
no no not eBay oh I didn't put a reserve
the buyers got in a bidding war over it
so now once the price is paid it sets
the precedent the most that I've ever
received from my cards as a set the
Conor McGregor Diaz cards when the
second time they fought sold for five
thousand dollars for the set Ronda
Rousey's sold for like thirty two
hundred when she fought Holly Holmes and
then I for sold sets for five hundred
it's all about what the market will bear
but once the price is there it sets a
tone now there's a grading on cards
called PSA you can take your sport card
or your wax pack send it in to PSA
grading they encase it and they grade it
one through ten right so here's an
example of how that works
I bought two wax packs of 1961 FLIR
basketball which is contains potentially
the Whoopi Wilt Chamberlain rookie card
okay and all we would love to open it
and find a world Chamberlain rookie card
two years ago that pack sold last year
that pack sold for $2,100 so already
I've almost made a hundred percent of my
money and I bought this thing four years
ago last week it sold for $3,300 graded
PSA seven they just end there like gold
bricks supply and demand
I've seen the recessions happen and when
I look at the artifacts I collect in the
military or the movie posters and these
cards they don't go down even the Wall
Street Journal once said when we're in a
recession some of the most valuable
things you can have to where to put your
money is in collectibles but you got to
know which ones to buy and you got to
how to write now your thing about
authenticity you need what you call a
CoA which is a certificate of
authorization gotta have that when you
buy so especially when you buy signature
items the movie Melissa McCarthy came
out in this year that she's nominated
for Best Actress Award for she plays a
writer
who is out of a job as far as a writer
and discovers that she can write letters
from old people in the past and falsify
their signatures and she's becomes a
forger of collectibles collecting money
this is a true story
and this movie was made she does a very
good start earn from the comedic actress
to dramatic actress which I'm gonna say
for you too I find that most comedians
whether you go back from Jack Lemmon in
the old days to comedians that you know
work the the the road in front of
audiences all the time to music
musicians like David Bowie and Mick
Jagger when they get in film they do
great jobs yeah we do drive incredible
I'm a better drama go yeah you're great
you know the drama but look at Lady gaga
nominated for stars one okay she's a
singer yeah but she had to act right
star turn four for sheriff shares
credible nominated for an actress Best
Actress worth great [ __ ] mask
she was great a moonstruck she wanted
the awards run right back then you know
so um it's a centering huh
interesting out of the turn my brother
frames [ __ ] yeah my brother in Jersey
but if you don't and I have a lot of
conversations about jerseys right he's a
big Jersey guy again CEO a certificate
of authenticity Mokpo soul went home
last time
JB Shetty sent me a picture of Berto
Clemente he got it from the museum so
when I go to New York I bring him all my
stuff he frames it would eat him was
back out for comic-con
he gives me my stuff cuz people send
pictures and stuff like that but years
ago he got caught up in love where he
bought him somebody who lied to him oh
he bought some false ones he for what
one for three and then he caught the guy
and he got his money back I got put in
jail
yeah I sure get arrested yeah no
absolutely Ria's [ __ ] thing it's a
huge business I can just sit here with
baseballs and slide him and go Mickey
Mantle it I hit Mickey Mantle signed
strangely enough
Mickey Mantle's autograph you used to be
able to buy for like 60 bucks he signed
multitudes you know a card shows of
multitudes of them but now his signature
is worth quite a lot of money and you
got to be careful with these signatures
if you don't storm right like I used you
know I've always lived at the beach and
the salt air can just ruin those
signatures so you got in case I'm right
you know you got to make sure you care
for them right
but these are gold bricks and a great
way to invest this word that's where my
investment has been done a lot in her
complaining used to invest in comic
books comic books are great also righto
he used to be a big comic right here
this guy's got original spider-man
sierens my buddy Gary he's one of my
best friends big collector of comic
books and I know comic books you're
talking they've gone for hundreds of
thousands you still with kids real quick
before you do it you know when the
biggest collectors of comic book says
who Nicolas Cage one of the biggest
collectors of comic books a matter of
fact thank you think he sold a rare
Superman comic or for a huge amount of
money it's a when I was when I left
Catholic school the kids I ran with
collectors and we would go to this guy's
house I was telling Lee those Italian
guys that lives with his mother in the
basement yeah he would wake up at 2:00
his his comic book store was only open
from 3 to 6
yep he was the laziest sack of [ __ ] in
the world he'd come up with a roll bad
breath and we just torment them and
arguing now I mean you know we were 12
year old [ __ ] you can't be worth this
and then when he would turn this back
we'd Rob or spider-man and then bring
him back and south to him two days later
than I saw you this yeah and we would
just torment them but I got into it I
got a fantastic four yeah and my fame I
got into the Silver Surfer yeah and I
bought all my hat all mice to go to show
no got him no I sold in the middle of a
country's round yeah I was telling Lee
we robbed the van one time we were kids
it was one of those comic book thing
conventions right and we were sitting in
front of the house and there was a van
on Liberty Avenue for like a week and it
was the summer or the t-shirts where you
pressed oh you mean that the the old
block t-shirt seems to make though the
old hot presses oh the hot presses right
go down this Jersey Shore yeah there'd
be a picture of Hitler and you go let me
put them on the t-shirt you did I did
you put a picture whatever you want
right you waited for two minutes the guy
melted your shirt with an iron that was
all in the back of that van we basically
emptied the van but the bus to comic
Ville went they were like an Hotel
Marriott sansho
ripped this poor guy off you took his
livelihood and you went to comic-con
it wasn't comma this was not common not
back then this is 1975 I got to do an
appearance at comic-con I probably owe
you big I don't know but I couldn't go I
want to go so I want to do myself out
and you and your brother wouldn't make
up yeah I'd be a lot of fun you know I
can't sit you know you were talking
about something before about social
anxiety I grew up in a bar you know I do
stand-up for a living the whole thing I
tell you what I cannot do let's go out
anymore we like go out at night and
party or what he's our milk those days
are long but that's not because you're
married with children no just something
about when I'm around a lot of people I
get uncomfortable like this ship finally
sailed this year we're having a little
Showtime I did a show for Showtime that
I went to the party I think my wife on
the dais and let's make it a date then
we both look each other after three
minutes I have been the last couple
years I have gotten more and more not
anti-social I don't have social anxiety
just when I see a lot of people I gotta
go notice I stopped going to the UFC's
I'm senior I've cut him down because it
just got too much it was too much for me
and I feel bad last week a kid contacted
me they want to do a party for Scott
coming it oh you know Scott Cunningham
was one of the guys that did the page
for us on Facebook and they overthrew
all the bunch of people for though
there's a war Scott Cunningham is the
nicest guy in the world right so this
guy said why don't we you know have a
party for Scott Cunningham and I go
number one you can't sit I live day to
day day the day I don't move I live when
somebody calls you Tuesday says you're
doing a movie for three months all that
planning we did was look I'm the
day-to-day guy I don't know what I'm
doing I don't know what I'm doing
Thursday I don't know what I'm doing
Friday and I'll be busy but I have no
[ __ ] idea I'll say one thing though I
told you to call me for this show on a
certain day and boom when you say you're
gonna do somethin or my business
business I'm going to do I don't like to
bother people nothing but I have a set
schedule what you have to do
and I don't know what it is and how to
tell this kid I go listen I appreciate
what you're doing when the time is right
I'm gonna fly Scott Cunningham out of
here and put him on the show well I know
that I have a month off I'm not gonna go
anywhere right but until that time they
don't we just get together and party I
know you obviously don't know me you
obviously don't go to the Comedy Store
on Tuesdays I have two spots on Tuesdays
right so I have that little window you
want to talk to me that's your window I
come there because I go right from the
stage straight to the car you know I can
understand that good I think personally
I think people say what is it like
getting older and I think the biggest
benefit to getting older is the
knowledge that we keep sore being and
getting more knowledgeable about things
but also the other thing about getting
older is we get much more particular I
mean speaking for myself in particular
whether it's you know picking someone to
date or a business venture or whatever
but through so many as you have all of
us had like Lee Howell do you 30 okay
the only person you of me is 31 years of
life experience right otherwise I don't
consider myself any different I just got
31 years of experience whatever I chose
to experience it at 31 years but we've
become more particular you see the
mistakes hopefully you see the mistakes
before they happen well you see the move
before they even evolve yeah exactly
it's used to have a great joke marijuana
doesn't make you lazy just makes you
realize that what you're gonna do ain't
worth doing smoke this joint don't see
that [ __ ] boss one more time that's a
good one that's a great joke he says
it's very true my brother he was a
police officer for roughly 25 years
right and he had a good line - he said I
never broke up a fight at a bar because
two guys just got done smoking a joint
never never broke up a fight between two
you guys just smoked a joint
no no no but it's so weird how I just I
get high I'll go out mm-hmm you know I
gonna do comedy I'm having a good time
once it I see more than eight people my
[ __ ] heart stops when I give blood I
gotta give blood with the windows got a
beat I gotta see a window I better hope
I never get that way Joey I'll have a
little step in the Octagon oh my god I
faint for the two I fainted I fainted at
uh you fainted I fail
a fight night at the palm really yeah
with me this had to be 15 years ago when
they were still doing the little UFC
help night at the pearl palm whatever
the [ __ ] that was I fainted I had
Ralphie May over here and I had a chick
over here with the biggest one well
Ralphie didn't pick you up I'm sure no
no no yeah I had the biggest fight I
fainted on Ralphie I had two offices I
pushed out free and I had a chick over
here with gigantic fake tits soft spots
on either way with the [ __ ] uh the
doctor who gave her the tits hilarious
so what happened was somebody got hit
really bad right and when they wiped him
they threw the towel in the towel and I
sold it's out hit the dang and blood
come out of you got blood anxiety oh my
god I seriously right there at the UFC
fight night what happens when they got
to take your blood of the doctors what
do you do
I put an iPod on and I looked the other
way and I they and they give me a
special nurse really she takes my blood
out with baby needles really I go to
acupuncture you overcome the needle fear
I love acupuncture I go to acupuncture
every other week to overcome that needle
fear interesting I just have I don't go
to acupuncture high no I actually you
get a good acupuncture right after the
occupy ocupado
I don't go to acupuncture high because
if the needle goes in the wrong way I'll
faint
interesting so I don't do nothing when
it comes to blood and all that stuff
Joey I know you're a tough son of a
[ __ ] from the early days were you like
this when you got in a fight as a kid
blood comes out it's not you you could
bleed to death it's you it's your blood
it's me
nachos smallest and I don't know when
it's gonna happen
uh-huh I could cut my thumb open and
nothing happened and when they I could
be in the shower chaining and just a
little things and that'll get you I
gotta get out of the shower and lay on
the floor naked wet Wow
if you never know what it's gonna hit
scaring never know when it's gonna hit
I've controlled it more now with my
needles mm-hm
when I go to the doctor I force myself
to give blood you know it's funny about
phobias because like obviously a lot of
people suffer from various photos are so
many phobias out there Steve McQueen out
of phobia he was scared of heights but
you know what he used to do
he started flying airplanes to get over
his fear of heights and he inches fly
airplanes he flow the he flew the old
Pitcairn and Stearman old airplanes that
were the world war 1 double wing
airplanes with the open cockpit so I
used to go up to his before he passed
away he had his ranch up in Santa Paula
California is home hit beach home Malibu
and the ranch up in Santa Paula and he
had an airplane hangar there we have
stored all those motorcycles and you
know planes and toys big toy collector
like Buck Rogers toys a huge collector
that's one of the things we had in
common we would go to collectors gun
shows together you know breakfast guy
never had his wallet on him I had to pay
for every damn breakfast for some reason
Steve McQueen never had it could crack
me up and his sons the same way Chad if
you're listening you know you are so
with that being said we went up there
and he lands his plane and he chases a
photographer away from like doing one of
these outside chases him away right and
we have a good day together a nice thing
and I was noticing as Steve was losing
weight you know and I didn't understand
why and a week later after we he said
something to me and I remember we drove
away just kept waving at us I could it's
the weirdest feeling I remember the
scene just you know that senior driving
away and just kept waving I you know
I've known for a good amount of time and
seen him consistently we're really good
friends and then a week later or maybe
two weeks later the National Enquirer
came out Steve McQueen cancer right
there's the picture taken that day of
him in the in the plane he chased a
photographer officer sold the picture to
the National Enquirer and they got the
supposedly allegedly they gathered the
story from understand back then from
what I heard in the inside and again I
know it's it's case that information was
leaked out of cedars-sinai
and then he went on his bout I think was
six months later give or take that he
passed they just released the film Tom
Horne that was his last film that came
out after the film the hunter was
actually a very good film really good
film it's really good it's a Western
it's a wedding really good was good is
good it was good Tom Horne has a whole
nother subject we can go into and then
he went through his treatments and he
went down to Mexico to Mexico to get
enema
coffee enemas every kind of holistic
possible treatment for this
and I remember Walter Cronkite on the
CBS News he they had a tape of him and
the raspy voice of Steve McQueen
thanking everybody for their thoughts
and he was gone a few days later if not
within a week later they operated on him
they found like a 10 or 15 pound tumor
inside he didn't survive the operation
and that was that was the last time we
heard from standing you know what he
passed at the age of 50 when you think
about he was 50 years old when he passed
amazing huh 1980 so he would be you know
hide right up in my mother 1980 you know
I'll start at the age of 50 another one
of my idols when I was a kid I had
certain idols tell me you're right tell
me your film idols growing up I'm gonna
give you a couple mind film Lionel's
growing up yeah the first one was
definitely child bronson after death
wish remember child you know Charles
Bronson's real name cha McCluskey
Charles buchinsky
chance : she changed it on he changed he
was that a Hollywood Boulevard or some
news yeah there but in the House of Wax
which was one of his first movies with
instant price back in the 50s his
credits are Charles buchinsky was before
he changed it to Charles Bronson and I'm
gonna tell you another funny story about
Charles Bronson want to hear this one
yeah this is a great job Bronson used to
live in Malibu I grew up right and his
wife he loved her to death she passed
away I think from breast cancer I forget
Jill Ireland Jill on July own so my
house my parents house where we live in
track has caught fire right so my dad
while it was being fixed he lived at the
bed-and-breakfast and because my dad was
a writer he grew up there and right and
he was up at the bed-and-breakfast on
Point Dume and he told me the story goes
I he goes it was driving me crazy
because for a couple of days all this
guy next door is doing is banging away
all day long sex all day long it's like
you know like you know coming through
the windows or that the you know the the
picture on the wall is like shaking like
a movie right and it's like I'm sitting
here trying to write us like every other
hour right banging away so he walks
outside when he who comes out of the
room Charles Bronson Charles Bronson was
there having a little weekend tryst
shall we say so
tosspot he was told - oh yeah but he
Stud that man never cha DOL's land i
mean it was a study was done in the
mechanic he's 51 years yeah and there's
another story who co-starred with him in
the mechanic
Jeb Michael another good friend of mine
Mary my high school friend
and then Jan Michael went a bad way -
who is he Jan Michael Vincent what's
what's preppers this for the for your
listeners okay Jan Michael Vincent the
original Brad [ __ ] there you go
a little breakfast that is the original
Brad Brad Pitt all the way you saw him
you were like good googly moogly God's
gift he hurt when I came from Cuba he
did a movie called the world's greatest
athlete says Nizhny that would Kurt
Russell yes coach that put him on the
map put him on the map put him on the
map but he did the blue love golden but
wealthy do we did something else well he
had the big TV show Airwolf but this is
all after that but the early on the film
Dan else he did it did my buddy John
Milius who did Conan the Barbarian who
actually designed the Octagon he was the
original designer of the Octagon they
were gonna put a moat around the Octagon
with deadly fish and all this that was
John Milius his mind working with the
graces back then anyway big Wednesday
Jan Michael Vincent Gary Busey who was
my neighbor that was his first movie no
no no this is this is when Jan was
really big this would a big Wednesday
and did two big movies back to back ok
look him up on IMDB did the mechanic and
that he did something he did a big [ __ ]
he did a big ensemble of stars and in a
horse race movie where they were racing
I forget the name of that he said it
that's Jan Michael mess it's got a big
rod he's got a oh wait a minute
the stuntman with Burt Reynolds that's
what it was yes has he gotten under Burt
Reynolds that Lauren or hopper and
Cooper Cooper exact same thing Burt
Reynolds is getting old he was the new
guy on the block and at the end Burt
Reynolds showed him how the [ __ ] that
was done with the dog yep remember they
kept torturing yeah animal cruelty guy
and Burt did the jump it's hilarious
movie [ __ ] great movie great movie
and then he did another movie that
nobody knows a button you gotta see the
cast a movie called defiance defiance
it's Jan Michael Vincent as
a longshoreman living in the village in
New York was the it was like one of the
original death wishes kind of switch
he's like you know in love with the
Latin girl yes he's reacting everybody
in the neighborhood walked in guy that
played the gang leader in there was was
scary as gang leaders that guy he had he
was also in the movie with about gangs
but that came out with Sean Penn and
Robert Duvall what was their they play
the LAPD well this is it Rudy robbed
collars collars collars
collar Sawa's but there's a guy in that
movie the [ __ ] let me tell you lose the
defiance menacing all right you got
Danny Aiello mmm in the beginning young
young Danny Aiello Paulie walnuts more
honest right young the black guy is some
star now young mmm-hmm defiant is a
movie that you'll never dream about yeah
it's about a gang that terrorizes a
neighborhood and Gen Michael and his
[ __ ] gesture and yeah [ __ ] them up
Jan Michael Vincent to watch them a Kent
the mechanic was on the other night the
old the new one the one with Jason
Statham was no no it's not no Jim I
convinced him though that was that was
all that was no no no you know like
Jason Statham I love Jason straight-up
until he did the mechanic cuz he stepped
on territory he stepped on and then I
wouldn't mind if he did it but they took
the main concept out of the movie
Charles Bronson was just not a killer in
that movie was a calculating calculating
yeah he'll do so it didn't look like it
was a murder in the beginning he blows
up the guy with the book everything was
he knew he knew you were susceptible of
heart attacks so he'd like firecrackers
next to you so you would have to jump up
in the end you'd die from a heart attack
so when they redid it I knew they were
gonna miss on the calculation part of
the movie and then at the end Jan
Michael gets in the car yeah blam it's
over and you wait there if you watch
this movie today you will hit me
tomorrow and go Joey go [ __ ] yourself I
watched the first half hour in that
movie left fell asleep then you don't
like movies fall asleep you know movies
because it's a 70s movie so it's shot
very slow
they made grave hour
methodically they made a Serpico I can
go on and on there's so many great
movies oh death wish that's wish you're
getting some one of the most that is one
of the most brutal rape scenes horrible
you will ever see Pope language hope
Lang was that hit the wife hope line
hope blade and and and yeah what's his
name with the original race he's Reber
gore whatever yeah yeah yeah he's still
the [ __ ] raped assume he was saying
oh Jesus I didn't say that
alright so let me tell you about Jan
Michael you ready you asked the question
though wouldn't you meet you and Michael
I met Jan Michael when I was in high
school at Santa Monica High School I was
in with my girlfriend Nina Mickelson
I'll never forget I could say names of
course yeah yeah so anyway Nina and I
were in a jacuzzi right and Joanne Jamm
married a woman who is our one of our
good friends and join Robinson right so
Joanne comes in really one of the hotter
girls in high school Jana good taste
and in walks Shan Michael Benson now I'm
a huge fan of his right now I'm in the
koozie I was in Jim Michael ventures
jumping on the jacuzzi and bottle
champagne opens and we're all having a
good time that's when I first met now
that I was everyone so I everybody
wanted but I didn't want to sit there
and watch that and go hey you went away
crying I when I lived in Malibu
there was a place called Trancas Trancas
restaurant at the corner of Trancas
Canyon Road at the end asuma beach it
was the hot spot it was a restaurant by
day but at night time on Friday and
Saturday nights there was a big area
there where bands used to come play we
partied hard there I would party with
get this group you ready for this group
my next-door neighbor was Jim my Tuscan
was a Gary Busey and this is the time
Gary Busey was nominated for the Academy
Award for Buddy Holly this is a horrible
accident this is before the accident
yeah he was my knee lived right next
door to me okay we were next door so
this is when he was nominated for the
Buddy Holly
movie for Best Actor and then he went on
to do big Wednesday so we party there
with Michael parks from then came
Bronson went under the Tarantino films
you know Michael parlous
David Carradine right Jan Michael
Vincent Gary Busey and a few other
people that are mixed
in there I once got asked at the bar I
was sitting at the bar and I can go so
many stories of this but there was a guy
in a cowboy hat right good-looking guy
you know having a spawn talking and said
hi how are you you know just having a
couple drinks he gets in this argument
with this guy right and he turns around
and goes look this guy gets on me you
backed me up and you didn't because I'm
gonna go for it here you know that guy
was Don Johnson young Don Johnson I
can't begin to tell you the
personalities came in and out of this
yes a lot of people know about Don
Johnson and I just remembered this time
Johnson was like a dude that hung out
with Frank Zappa Don Johnson do use it
big partier
he was like a young Bruce Willis back
yes yes yeah with Frank Zappa and he
also hung out with the Allman Brothers
mmm he partied but the [ __ ] Allman
Brothers like I read this thing about
him that he even contributed lyrics to
one of the Allman Brothers song that was
getting high or something like that he
was he was dating somebody he's got a
very introduces that guy that was dating
somebody that was big then he got a boy
in his dog and he just blew up after
then he married somebody marry Melanie
Griffith but no before that matter that
matter these mother first he do it
do it yeah yeah yeah he did some kinky
[ __ ] well before I forget yeah but good
body of work I'm Don Johnson you know
Miami I love it
oh yeah he's great what we've got done
the Tarantino films he does great job
yeah I love done let's get back your
original question about question about
Jan Michael Vincent he took a bad turn
he had substance abuse issues when did
he take the time like Chad McQueen after
Steve died started producing movies and
acting in movies and he had Jan Michael
Vincent on the tail end his career
poster wolf post everything to star in
this movie right before the movie was
made Jan had a bad car accident went
right through the windshield cut up the
beautiful face he had you know whatever
and he had abuse problems drugs and
alcohol and now if you pull up a picture
he's like 72 or 74 he's had to have his
leg amputated due to I think diabetes
take a look at him Lee pull up a picture
okay Jan jnt oh no Joe John Johnson pull
up Jan Michael Vincent first Oh
we'll be married first uh he married
Melanie Griffith Nona Griffith first
yeah but he dated somebody when he was
she was older than he was if that's why
the Melanie Griffin marriage was kinky
I'm because he dated a mother so he was
young when she met him he was usually 16
or 18 years old well yeah they she dated
she was 15 when they first started
living together yeah but then they
remarried in 89
you know she married Antonio Banderas
right you know he had open-heart surgery
four years ago are they still together
paramedic oh I know no I don't think
they're so you pull up Jim Michael
Mitchell you not gonna believe this
picture but I saw him maybe 20 years ago
he had no teeth I didn't see him
physically somebody brought a picture of
him up where is he living
well you had a he had a ranch north of
where I lived in Malibu there he is
there and see this look at him young and
look at him now
it's crazy that was Brad Pitt you're
right it's the best way to put it
he was the original Brad Pitt amputated
and his leg got amputated for what
reason I think because he developed
diabetes he lost a limb to infection now
there you are Lord blesses East East
twelve years older than I am
this poor guy he's got a glass eye I
mean he's just a mess
that's really [ __ ] sad it's sad it's
really sad I had the world by the
fingertips finally said the hardest
thing I ever did he told me he said he
loved making the movies but the hardest
thing you're dead is you know it's the
TV's heart you get a series you're on
that damn set twelve sixteen hours a day
he goes it's the hardest he ever did was
the Airwolf series you know it's crazy
going back all that what a shame yeah
Lisa yeah I didn't know how to speak the
language so my original hero
I love Dick Van Dyke dick Van Dyke was
my that was how I learned how to speak
English he is and what watching Dick Van
Dyke because of his ability to
articulate and the way he would talk he
is one of the nicest men you Allah yeah
yeah I did a movie wasn't it well he
wasn't Lee still about two months 90
walking around I think he still lives at
the Marina towers yeah I should say that
but anyway
I see him all the time he just did a
live TV show didn't they like Mary
Poppins yeah he did my Obamas that's
right am I gonna seen in my papa he was
great oh you mean the movie the original
yeah see he was the car good for him we
just showman you're talking about it
yeah you're talking about a great
showman I mean listen I don't mean to
sound like I'm getting older and we
always do that my day and my day but
isn't it different today the types of
talent that we see today think that I
think for the last 15 years and they
give people an Oscar you could wipe your
ass with that Oscar like the guy from
and I don't I'm not saying nothing bad
about it I'm not disrespecting him
what's the movie with the chick that
beat out the husband ex-husband couple
years back Hurt Locker Hurt Locker the
guy that won the Academy we're a lot her
locker her lucky out that guy didn't
have the class to win the Academy Award
so it was that ready yeah yeah yeah
there's a bit they don't have what they
don't have that movie star let me give
you one of mine are uh that Rat Pack ish
now it's different
Colburn let me clean let me listen this
movie star it is thrown out so cheaply
today because what I grew up to
appreciate movie stars John Wayne is a
movie star by the way was his new
whiskeys in response to the podcast
he's a whiskey I just got a bottle the
LA the Duke did you I gotta check it out
his sons coming out with a whiskey I met
him I just got the bottle the others and
try it out tonight maybe can I tell you
my John Wayne story you mad general way
I met John oh [ __ ] did you meet all
these [ __ ] in Malibu now I met
John Wayne in Dallas Texas I was 10
years old roughly and the movie true
grit came out raises price now back in
those days they had premiers and you
bought a ticket to the premiere right
people were lined up around the block
you know the old days so we're out of
theater my dad got us two tickets to the
theater right my brother and I were like
10 and 12 let's say 8th and 10th I don't
know exactly I gotta go look I wrote
about it in my book but I I can't tell
you exactly so we're in the theater the
theater is packed we
have the two end seats about two-thirds
down right down comes John Wayne in the
aisle beside my seat we turn around and
he looks like a giant right
a giant it's John Wayne right he walks
by I'm all shaky and I go hey Duke right
he does like a little 180 turns around
him he goes
hey little pilgrim my brothers in my jaw
went are you kidding he talked to us he
called me little pilgrim I will never
forget that the rest of my life one
other one I don't forget is in and when
I was five and Bryan was seven we were
in Philadelphia and this tall black man
walked in and we recognized him from
sports and we went and said hi to him
just like he walked by I said hi he
turned around and spent five to ten
minutes talking to us you know what his
name was Cassius Clay not Muhammad Ali
Cassius Clay that five to ten minutes
that he spent with me as a kid and my
brother Bryan had an effect on me just
like John Wayne that I remember for the
rest of my life and this is one of the
reasons I know you see me in shows I
never say no in an autograph I never say
no to picture as long as I'm very
suspect for but above all I never say no
to children because the effect you can
have on a kid right do you want that to
be the most positive confirming
experience they can have when you had a
chance to share your your presence with
them right
I always believed we should be role
models we're out there you know we have
to get back does it doesn't like to
experience that true effects on me true
effects but John Wayne and Glen Campbell
was behind of no offense John Wayne
right now let me give you my other big
Idol I wish you ask yourself out of all
the film stars and stuff what one or two
would you love to have dinner with to
sit down and spend an evening with right
you know - Errol Flynn
I read his biography my wicked wicked
ways I grew up watching all his movies I
freaking loved that he was just such a
star I loved that he was tough and he
would fight stuntmen and he was stood up
for himself you know just a New Zealand
tough guy travelled the world
just an adventurer
just something about it man just there's
no Errol Flynn's today you know there's
no John Wayles today when I was rolling
up on you I'm sorry if I sound
old-fashioned there's some exceptional
scene amazing dinner one night what's
that I'm a mrs. marrying dinner as a kid
and my hero crushed my hero who as I
grew up another [ __ ] immigrant [ __ ]
house and we were immigrants and I made
a big deal mom loved me not even I wanna
watch Batman she would be straight in
the face when she go that man's a [ __ ]
well like only talking about she was
about my old money call I said it she's
right she wears a cape and then she
would sing me the Batman song in Spanish
the Adam West me Adam was why he got
Batman fell I met thinking a cool old
Batman and I would say stop it stop it
so my superhero [ __ ] without the window
right you know I went I was raised I was
very fortunate I had somebody like you
of my life my dad died when I was three
but the guy who baptized me picked me up
every Saturday on 88th Street took me to
42nd Street to watch movies and I only
seen two kid movies the love bug and
lover was greatest athlete after that it
was all the valachi papers' he would
just tell me not to tell my mother
mm-hmm don't say no that's back when the
rating system you know no that was look
there was no there was no real rating
system back that was lonely you pay you
know nobody a [ __ ] it's like you know
what remember when Midnight Cowboy came
out it was raining at yeah yeah yeah
seventies when you just go hey my father
sent me to the store he wants a bottle
whiskey and a pack of cigarettes all
right they gave it there but you know
one day your father came in and the guy
goes your son keeps coming in for
cigarettes I don't smoke I don't drink
the smoke what the [ __ ] man I would
never was a different country different
yeah it was a very different country so
you went to if you went to a ray that
actually your parent about 40 seconds
only he covered the spread and the kid
wasn't gonna have a nightmare dig them
in you know my my big rated X story okay
back and grimmer Santa Monica Boulevard
when they were the
okay let's go back to Boogie Nights so
you were raised all here now
pretty much no no really - how old teen
on I moved out here from Philadelphia
when I was 15 in Malibu which was like
culture shock Joey right no German it
was culture I never saw beautiful blonde
girls like that running out in the no no
never saw Beach I had a house not a
beach so no yeah you going there to get
the measles yeah so I didn't even notice
that Delaware's number one [ __ ] state
for cancer sure cuz Philly and New
Jersey piss in the water and dump all
this [ __ ] in it and it ends in Dover oh
Jesus whatever the [ __ ] it is Delaware
thank God you been out here since you
were 15 I came out here at 15 and Malibu
was a because I've heard stories gonna
be different that Malibu was like your
neighbor was Sinatra you're me and this
guy was this guy and I want to live this
guy here's the thing people think oh you
lived in Malibu you and nobody came up
to like TMZ then come up your bow no no
it was a different world nobody came be
out for the camera knocked on your door
and a camera what - Steve McQueen's
house yeah I'm not come up you know I
got so many stories about that but
listen 15 going out to Malibu hormones
flying all I want to do was lose my
virginity and learn how to serve I
learned how to surf first and then I
became Baywatch before Baywatch and
everything else followed its natural
course but people think when you live in
Malibu you have to be rich no that's not
true I'm sure we were middle class I
might and I wrote about in my book my
family and I went broke on more than one
occasion as a family you know we picked
ourselves up I bought out $75 from my
mom when I was 16 to go over weekend
skiing in Mammoth that's all it took $75
with all my friends that was my sure the
gas my shirt at the condo the lift
tickets a little bit I didn't have it I
was like 16 right I wasn't working
actively at that time my mom said I
don't have a son she came to me two days
later handed me 75 bucks so when on my
trip had a great trip two weeks later I
I'm up in one in the morning over here
my parents in the next room talking
about of the camp a the $575 a month
rent we had for the house at that month
what are we gonna do my mother gave me
75 bucks to go enjoy myself I told
myself I would never borrow money for my
parents again I start working started my
first business making jewelry and high
school sort of pulling down a thousand a
month if my parents needed money I gave
it to him you know that's the kind of
thing I think kids needs to go through
to learn
the self-worth and the ability to take
care of things and not be so entitled
and have everything given to I'm real
big on that okay what do we know if we
don't know we don't do it right so at
different times Joey I'm raising my
daughter seventy style I'm raising my
daughter the same way my mother raised
me I'm very I live in an area here where
all the answers unless you have a kid
all the answers to your questions that
you ask of what's going on in society
you have no idea because it's a
different world out there I go to the
YMCA I take this film that the YMCA
mm-hmm you know many times I went to the
YMCA and saw the parents sitting outside
the pool texting and their kids in the
pool with the landing that's horrible
with the nanny
that's horrible all these white kids
with Mexican [ __ ] nannies and their
parents sitting outside texting where's
the bond with you and your child the
only bond that they give now is the
money bond everything that's replaced by
money my daughter goes to a self-defense
school I know the celebrity kids are
there because their parents never show
they dropped off by uber they're eight
nine you don't have a parent and I'm
watching not one parent to come watch
you I'm a godfather I picked my boys up
from school we cannot busy a walk rogon
last week he was talking about going to
a restaurant and both parents were on
their phones and the two kids both had
iPads and nobody was talking to one if
that doesn't tell what we're trying to
come across that will retire that's how
it happened I communicate I that's why I
don't like to listen but nine years ago
a commercial came on and a guy comes
into like that sales room when he goes
he starts giving out plane tickets I
think those are ladies and gentlemen the
vacations Oh more no more emails no more
this [ __ ] we're going back to belly to
belly sales yeah this is a commercial
for like copiers or something and I said
in my world I don't care if it's 2018 or
2019 I don't care about the technology
I'm the John the San Francisco 49ers in
1981 Dallas is coming in here and given
me two points
this is my house yeah this is how I live
my life so if you wanna text you could
text all you want you text all you want
I'm not gonna text you back
I I don't go into those holes but I know
that I live with my life and you missed
a thousand-dollar gig well sorry you
didn't [ __ ] call me you know I'm one
of those guys that it's my playing field
you and I touched on this before before
I go in on one thing I Malibu back then
today you have to have money look mal
this is it back then the rich all lived
at the beach right the middle-class we
live in the canyons you know we did
whatever I was only quarter mile from
the beach and you know McQueen was down
right on the beach whatever along with
do you name it that lived on the
Spielberg and Stallone and you know I go
Dustin Hoffman I don't know dude they're
all they're all picking their fruit and
feeling their bananas like everybody
else in the market they put on their
pants like we do they do everything else
I don't get I don't get it crazy when I
see celebrities but there are a couple
that have blow me away and that was
obviously John Wayne and obviously
Cassius Clay and obviously the first
time I met Steve McQueen right and then
it just we became friends and everything
became cool and it just taught me a lot
about that there's someone Ali's
daughters Laila the other one used to do
comedy I didn't know that pictures up on
the wall yes talk and she came one night
she goes my father's coming to watch me
as soon as I heard that I got my car I
left
seriously thought I would have a nervous
breakdown if I would talk to him he was
like no no I know he was great he was
great no I garage I know I know all
those things about Joey remember when we
talked you were on my show last we both
have we have a things a comic we have
one big thing in common we both aye-aye
owned and ran telemarketing companies
you know in my 20s and my 30s and you
did the telemarketing too and we both
talked about how much we learned from
telemarketing back in those days you
know running boiler rooms with a hundred
salespeople and you know all that type
stuff and the experience we had Muhammad
Ali next to my one of my offices in West
LA is to be a school and I met Muhammad
many times over the years he would come
to the school to pick up his kids right
no entourage no nothing you know what he
did for the kids when they came out of
school
tricks for like 10-15 minutes this is
Muhammad Ali today entourage is I need
this guy I need that guy but I being
about a boom you know it's like it's
just different Joey you know I'm not
that guy and I know I have this little
little niche level compared to these big
stars and everything but I just like to
keep it real Joey just it's just more
comfortable for me we can fly I came
from a different place you know I came
from a different place also where I'm
not I'm not
it takes a lot to [ __ ] impress the
[ __ ] out of me along the guy chased when
I moved here I was a Joe Rogan to this
super one day but I thought white next
to us was James Coburn in the Acura NSX
love James Cole and I go rogue and chase
that [ __ ] lose my license I'm
like chase that [ __ ] we chase
them then they just blew away from us
they ended up working on our list with
him I love that show I did two episode
love that sure talk to him a little bit
yeah the second I did one episode but I
work two days yeah yeah the next day I
brought a Bruce Lee and you know he
trained with him yeah he came and so did
McQueen I had a I think Richard Pryor
was one of my big idols growing up like
a lot of my friends saw me I still
remember you bringing the albums over I
saw him at the comedy store yeah I said
I'm gonna come back you look back in the
70s you see everybody everybody you used
to go to the comedy store then also I
when I was in high school I learned that
the greatest date in the world is to
take your girl to dinner and go to the
comedy store because you comedians
closed up that deal for that night just
by making her lap girls loved one thing
more than anything along with many
things they left they loved to laugh if
you can make your girl laugh you're told
it's over while they're laughing you
slip the dick race anyway I would go to
the comedy store back I started going
into the comedy store in 1975 right I
think Missy opened it only few years
before that or so David Letterman was
the host every night at the Westwood
comedy store which was on Westwood
Boulevard and I would go up and I used
to one
that the the rain the fires came coming
through every fire in Malibu it's just
terrifically I mean this last time I
call it Julie you called me Thank You
Joey that's right and you called make
sure we're safe yeah England and I
appreciate it but I saw my home in
Malibu I'm now in another area by the
beach and you know but I thank you so
much sure they're so nice oh you won't
be doing
I lost believe me terrific firemen oh I
remember fire one of these men they got
tough [ __ ] jobs in LA so when the
rent when the fires hit and then the
rains come the mudslides happened so one
of the roads came down which closed off
you know there's only one way in and out
of Malibu from Santa Monica right
otherwise you got to drive another hour
all the way around so my offices were in
Santa Monica and I could not get to
Santa Monica so my company at the time
and I'm like a 21 year old kid right and
you know I own part of the company so I
wound up living at the Hyatt House which
back then used to be called the riot
house I live next to the comedy show you
was this this is going back I'm gonna
call this at nineteen to be safe I'm
gonna call this at 1978-79
okay so I lived there for almost two
months you know what I did every night
Joey I went to the comedy store I was
there I'd say at least five out of seven
nights saw everybody Robin Williams you
name Jim Carrey at 18 Riano just saying
oh my god this guy's gonna be one of the
biggest talents the world ice clay when
he was sleeping on Mitzi's couch you
know I won't trade in those experience
for the world walking in and there's
Santana walking in and Led Zeppelin
walking out and these are the days when
these for the TVs for the windows
remember the almost famous days by the
way Bohemian Rhapsody one of the
greatest movies ever seen have you seen
it yet yeah yeah the house is incredible
scream it's something greatest movie but
you know I'm excited cuz I just watch it
about days ago it was damn good damn it
I I personally it was a foot today's
standards today standard a yeah yeah it
was good
Raimi was really gray Malick he's he's
up in the Lord yeah yeah he's getting
great jobs but anyway there was the days
back then you know it's just it's just
different I used to have I think I saw
every concert that came in and out of
the for you name it I saw it you know
just one of the things I would you would
do it
here I was doing in New York yeah okay
it was the same type you're hitting
Dangerfield you know back there never
went to a comedy club no I was a Madison
Square Garden typing [ __ ] oh I
want to see Sinatra one time at Radio
City mm-hmm but it's like we were just
talking about this earlier on a podcast
last week about how there's no middle
class like when I was a kid I went to a
knick game yeah you know what are you
doing tonight nothing you know sit at
home like an answer we got a half hour
we can make it to a Knick game right go
we'll miss the first ten minutes right
let's go to a Knick game and we go watch
and you still home the game start at
7:30 so you're home by 9:30 10:00 st. so
I grew up watching the knick game and
it's so weird how families today cannot
afford to go to a Laker game you know
Attica ramilya 3 cannot afford to go to
a leg again add it up and it eats me up
alive between the parking the tickets
the food is 300 bucks 400 bucks somebody
a couple weeks ago so that that type of
[ __ ] burns me up that I had I love
basketball growing up I loved Bernard
King I loved Julius Erving
I loved all that [ __ ] but I had dinner
with Julius Erving when did you in Utah
we work my brother I had him announced
the Chicago Bulls against the Utah Jazz
in Utah when Michael Jordan was sick as
a dog throwing up before the game had
six or seven points during the game this
is game five right there down by like 15
points I'm I don't know exactly for
those watching he comes out at halftime
that one of the greatest single man
performances I've seen in my life
he scored like 42 points won the game
won the series I had Michael sell out
the game I'm on the floor with them
celebrating the confetti is coming down
man I'm telling you Joey is not all
about the paycheck it's about these
experiences that we learn from them
that's a million-dollar experience
incredible you know just to see that I'm
gonna tell you a story real quick you
touched on Frank Frank Sinatra I had the
pleasure of seeing him three times in
concert two of the times I saw him my
dad used to be a boss gambler at the
Riviera Hotel in Vegas where they fill
in the movie Casino now back in 72 to 75
who was runnin Vegas Joey okay our
you know what I'm saying it wasn't the
bean counters and the corporations and
all and the Riviera was one of the
hottest spots in the world now back then
when you look at a pit boss in your boss
gambler my dad I was commenting but I
can't control this let's play in
blackjack when I was 18 19 years old
thanks to my dad and casinos right
cutting my teeth on the blackjack tables
right my brother Brian sue
Shecky Greene one of the greatest
comedians ever come on do you like
Shecky Greene yeah I love Shecky Greene
I had seen him a million times right
right so we saw Shecky Greene one night
so we're in Delmonico's you know down
and some lobsters courtesy of the Revere
hotel because we didn't pay for anything
right they didn't care if you gambled
gamble or not we got the Frank Sinatra
suite dinners paid just come have a good
time that's the way it was back then it
was different right so my dad says well
sons you know where do you want to go
out Elvis Presley's over at the Hilton
one of his last concert tours right the
bloated Elvis whatever but I never saw
Elvis and so Brian I look at each other
you know Shecky Greene was really funny
Brian wasn't he let's go see Shecky
Greene again tonight my dad could have
had his first Road Elvis Presley I would
have had a chance to see the King Elvis
Presley one time just say I saw one time
I regret that to this day Joey
I regret that this isoh Barbra Streisand
Liza Minnelli I mean you name it Frank
Sinatra you name it back then it was
just easy nowadays it's ticketron buy
your ticket stand in line that's not for
me I hate standing in line personally
this Laurie I drove finally go to GNC to
get my little energy thing and I saw a
bunch of people standing in front of
heat I [ __ ] open my window yell them
it's a 10:30 there was 40 people waiting
on line for [ __ ] eggs how [ __ ]
was that oppression me know it sound
like the depression there waiting in
line for waiting on line for eggs really
over Eddie there's a little like
hopefully the little restaurant isn't
bad it's one of your favorite little
places I know it's not one of my
favorites no not at all it's a nice
place I'll go with my wife till Thursday
okay after we drop the baby off
sometimes but because the baby likes
[ __ ] Dennis so it's the pancakes the
way there are Denny's they've been
friends for years so I don't get the
glory but my point being that it's one
of those restaurants where people stand
on line to get breakfast
let the brunch nothing bothers me more
then gets on my nerves than a nice
weight and I was right there at the
light oh well you can be fathom you know
what the [ __ ] are you doing and they
just look at me and I just keep going in
on the way back I'd be better [ __ ]
dummies eggs everybody got eggs
yeah and you're waiting on line for
those [ __ ] I think if it was a snake
frog Diablo or a lobster something
officer frog Diablo lobster Fra Diavolo
one of my favorite dishes - have a
possum you know my favorite says
spaghetti Puttanesca now you don't want
to call Puttanesca with that isley it's
called that's horse pasta right they
used to get together and just put
everything to put in the pot right to
make some good pastas so called
Puttanesca very popular dish you're very
popular olivey yeah isn't that the
olivey one's got a lot of hours to put
into the night's got the olives no yeah
it's good - all that stuff it's good how
good are you at poker like if you had to
rate somebody from one to ten how good
are you at poker
now you've been playing all these gee
I'm gonna have Lea do something for us
okay and you tell me how good I am
Lea no no no I want you to tell I'm
pro-rated I can play I am and you do all
this stuff in Vegas and stuff like that
yeah when I get time at the the World
Series of Poker is one that you know
every poker Punk wants to play it I just
got back from the Bahamas where Poker
Stars flew me down and I played a 25,000
dollar entry tournament you've had to
pay $25,000 cash to enter but first
prize is 5.1 million dollars now I
played the main event in Vegas I went
out on the high cut out on day two I my
entry fee you know you put up the 25
grand you know you take the shot right
5.1 million somebody wins Joe you're
playing against
hassles Adam it's fine you know why when
I stand across a night up to fight
somebody and ass bar somebody whatever
when I'm standing across and you know I
got a maybe have an announcer or
something like that or if I'm standing
across sitting across from you playing
poker you bleed like I do you breathe
like I do I've got a heart you've got a
brain I'm not gonna I try not to get
intimidated sure I have been in the past
but I know my skills so I look at it
like this everything I do in life comes
down to three
be s C stands for balls skill and
confidence and if I'm lacking any one of
those three qualities I'm not gonna sit
down at the table but you also need that
20% luck Factory always got to have that
20% luck factor to win
I played the top pros and the World
Series of Poker at last I played in the
main event was about five years ago I
was in the top 10% of chip leaders for
five days Joey 12 hours a day you're
playing poker right you make one mistake
you're gone it's like fighting you know
and there's an endurance level that goes
with that which makes it kind of a sport
or as a sport because it's mentally you
know and physically wearing right you
make one wrong mistake you're knocked
off just like you get knocked out in the
Octagon and the eye that feeling you get
when you take somebody for an all-in as
they say and and you take their chips
it's almost like knocking him out you
know I'm not at the poker table to make
friends I never lie in person I never
lie to you Joey I tell the truth all day
long DRI don't talk right but at the
poker table it's legal to lie and I do
what it takes to win and I want your
chips it's as simple as that how many
told him is dude we I try to do I used
to be on Full Tilt's team I was on Full
Tilt Poker see Full Tilt's pokers team
okay if you remember that site remember
back in the wild days the wild wild west
when everybody was happening there was a
Black Friday back then when the
government you know kibosh Full Tilt
Poker two months before that happened
the owners called me up and they said
you're playing so well you know I've got
won a couple titles what's money of
course with the USC status they go we're
gonna I was what they call red Pro they
paid me like $35,000 to play and they
gave me only rate back which amounted to
thousands you can make each month then
they said well we're gonna put you in
all the TV commercials we're gonna pay
all your entry fees into the World
Series we negotiated a 70/30 cut meaning
I get to keep 70% of the winnings right
and some of those entries are ten
thousand five thousand tooth you know
it's not Joey right so do me a favor go
to card player comm and you'll see a
thing of the top says players and just
put in my name there's no hiding it I
don't lie people walk up to you and say
hey I won $5,000 last night playing
poker or playing blackjack
well that guy doesn't tell you about the
ten times he lost two or three right
he just tells you what he want okay I
have a program on my computer for 1415
years now no matter where I play poker
blackjack football bet I only bet on
football I never bet fights
equal-opportunity announcer I play poker
I bet football games and I play
blackjack I will tell you I can tell you
everywhere I played the date I played
where I played what I played how much I
want how much I lost tally at the end of
the month tally at the end of the year
why because I'm real with myself I
treated like a business and I've only
had two losing years in 15 years
honest-to-god car player dot-com how
much money's to say I have won on the
pro circuit against the pros Joey I have
top cashes and recent cashes what's the
total amount oh here we go Oh total
winnings 338 814 say it so people
understand three hundred thirty eight
thousand eight hundred fourteen dollars
I can play I can now what's the rake
real quick cuz okay you saw Molly's game
yes I saw my loved it love I played with
those people Joey I have and it got in
the game got too big you can lose
everything you have friggin own in your
life and one night guys sitting down
playing to four hundred blinds putting
quarter-million dollars on the table
your twenty thousand den somebody raises
it to eighty thousand you got a pair of
kings and there's an ace on the board
you're sweating balls what do you do
it's pressure Joey and you don't want to
play beyond your means
so the rake what they meant in the rink
where she said she did not rake the
games until towards the end but any
poker player including Gary is a big big
poker player it's like you don't make
the five million she made I think him
you know that's just not on tips you
know they do tip a lot you'd be amazed
how much money flies around these games
so you know you get the good-looking
girls to serve you get the gourmet chefs
you put up the man's cave and you have a
game so the rake is you go into a game
and some of these games and they'll say
because casinos rake the tables that's
how they make their money right but they
take a short rake in these games
they'll take like say five percent of
the pot so let's say in one of these big
games like Molly's game were those hands
as an example could be anywhere from a
$20,000 to a $50,000 hand
pull of 5% if you're playing 30 hands 20
30 hands an hour
do the math look how much being raked
off that table right that's how those
kind of games has they depicted in the
theater that's what the rake is but if
you do that you're a casino and that
makes it illegal right so home games
there should be no rake you pull out a
$5 like what we do my home games you
pull out a $5 chip to add up over the
night to pay for all the food you bought
for the group rights everybody's cool
about that right you do your games you
don't make a profit on you i try to make
profit by playing by the way that's
where the houses and make them you know
it's you're not supposed to Joey this
illegal so it's wearing a table as I can
said I'm not a card game it's okay but
that's not a dice guy but in Molly's
game it's alright they're people that
don't understand a watch I found that I
found it to be a really good movie I
thought it was true she's great
I'm big fan he's great I watched all the
movies on the point she does a
four-metre anything all she's just so
beautiful I love redheads
oh when she's on skis I'm almost having
a [ __ ] wrong way go she's [ __ ]
beautiful weather what is your schedule
looking like what is your next card game
tomorrow night okay yeah and you do one
a month yeah I try to do one a month you
know I built a poker room my house and
bbo poker tables if you guys want to
find a great place and make custom-made
poker tables bbo poker tables fantast
they may be a beautiful table they put
an image of me jumping in the middle of
the table and you know put like just
it's just beautiful and it's in my game
room it's bringing a lot of collectibles
and I have built a game room my house
and you know bringing I got the chef
coming in tomorrow making the food but
you know what you know what the menu is
tomorrow night you ready the best best
maybe back ribs you'll ever eat in your
life sauce on the side I'm not everybody
wants the sauce great mashed potatoes
corn bread red velvet cake for dessert
what Johnny Walker Blue Label what you
want you got it you're at my house let's
enjoy ourselves well ten dollars a hand
out of the thing to pay for the food you
know there we go
I wind up I wind up going to the hole
anyway I spent more money than they did
it costs a lot of money but a nice game
but I've got some really good
friends action players and it's a man
cave come on it's great you sit around
with your friends some girls are really
good players too you know they come over
and just have a good time especially
you're in win the monday night football
games or something's happening it's just
a good excuse to kick back I was in a
game last night I went downtown I was I
think I played a four in the morning
slept till twelve but you know what I
got the weekend off Joey when do I get a
weekend off
you know I know this is a slum it's it's
I love it and people say why don't you
take a vacation
I'm home I'm living a vacation I'm home
I love being on the road I love when I
get home
where's your next fight Melbourne
Australia when two weeks that's right
love moment speaking of poker they have
one of the greatest poker casinos in the
world they're the crown casino and
there's some good action players there
so I'll be down there so you played
poker all around the world yeah if I'm
in if I'm around the world anywhere
there's a poker room I'd like to relax
with the night before show I don't I
don't drink a lot Joey you know I'm like
a nun the night before a show I want you
I want to be ready yeah no I want to be
a hundred and fifty percent for show
night right not 24:04 yeah maybe so
party like I guess so party late in 2000
kidding that though I probably die if I
do some of the stuff I did when I was 24
I can't even bother when I was 54 now
okay I can't even do what I was doing
two years ago no I stopped with the
edibles
you said they were hurting your stomach
they might hurt my stomach I just felt
that there was something going on I
didn't know what it was I end up finding
I was lactose tolerant oh so they go I
don't still run this but now I don't
really want to eat CBDs you're doing the
CBD or a little bit yeah in the CBD
water I believe in them so much I love
well I mean there listen you go your
pharmacy it we all know the marijuana
well I talked about on the podcast
forever marijuana should be legalized
them all for it whether I do it or not
that's just it's not the case I just
believe it should be legalized the whole
thing about CBDs I'm tired of NFL
players getting addicted to opiates
because they stuff them down their
throat right I think Terrell Davis from
the from the Broncos if I'm not mistaken
just went public and said if he had CBDs
he would he would have a longer career
in the NFL I mean I my friend's mother
suffers from MS couldn't walk CBDs two
weeks later she's walking Joey no it's
it's just walk
phenomenal it's phenomenal it really is
Joe Montana just made a major investment
in a marijuana company right that's
gonna be big in California you know this
is the wild wild west people are getting
in there is legal ice and everybody is
real it's better for you then drinking
those straight John's shots of bourbon
and scotch you and I both know that I
know you know it was anxiety post well I
have something for you it's always a
pleasure when you come on this [ __ ]
show would you bring us today yeah all
right my friend Dave Manley owns a
company named mm a bobble heads calm
have you seen these yet yeah okay
he's amazing and he really did I
appreciate this man so much because he's
so passionate about his business he
makes the best figures ever so he made
one of me cowboy Cerrone Brian Ortega
there's a real cool one coming out but I
can match a name Chuck Liddell and so
here this is there's only a thousand of
these made and this is my gift to you
thank you brother so a booth buff a
bobble head
look at the quality in the detail though
he's it's unbelievable even the box is
nice yeah it comes with a certificate of
authenticity pull gently out anything
that's it
very nice I wonder what this will go for
in 30 years
tuxedo and everything yes I am well they
so check out the fight card look at the
detail on the fight card let me show you
some show your hands I gotta get done
last isn't got a bunches I can't see I
believe here that's one computer now
what he's done is he took it another
step further for Christmas and you can
have many be Christmas ornament I like
it that great now here's an example of
collectibles remember round five the
figures they made the other figurines
that were made for the UFC called round
five you there you go Joey you in my
heart all the time my pleasure
right there so they made a thousand of
those round five and when they first
came out with the one I know for mine he
could buy it for like 39 bucks you can't
touch it on eBay for under $250 now
there's only a thousand at the
he's originally sold sign for like 79 39
unsigned but not just mine but the
others cuz they're limited and made so
well this will be a five hundred dollar
three to five hundred dollar item in
about three years
my prediction knowing collectibles not
because it's me
screw that right screw that it's just
supply and demand they're not making
this they don't make action figures for
any this is it ten years from now we'll
be watching porn stars and somebody will
come in with their nobody me Bruce buff
don't I'm a made though don't throw away
your stuff I got some big things that
we'll be talking about this year I can't
mention him right now I just had a
really cool cameo in the Holmes and
Watson movie with Will Ferrell one of
the nicest guys I've ever met in my life
and and Riley who's so talented what a
great character actor he is that guy
right got a couple big announces some
products coming out surrounding lets get
ready to rhumble and my it's time
trademark but you know what Joey you
know it's really taken off big is at
Bruce Buffer calm
I always got approached to do
championship introductions and I did and
the people paying me some ridiculous
money for him but the fans are so great
okay I'm all about the fans and I give
away I get partial proceeds to children
military and animal charities like I
just gave to make a wish and I do
championship
introductions for audio and videos where
anybody I did this for you before when I
was on the show or introduce you like a
champion and the cage just got your
championship now people are ordering
audios like Steve Amy o Chooch I did a
birth of a baby the birth of his baby
then he put it on social media I'm doing
more birth of babies announcements you
know coming out now or whatever you know
that kind of thing and weddings tons of
weddings podcast intros all that stuff
it's grown up into a whole other
business my partner Kristen and I were
just doing a lot and then it goes into
the business aspect repeat and what
people want them for products and their
businesses and and I'm and I'm doing a
lot of motivational speeches teaching
branding and marketing and be a winner
speech you know positive I I don't want
to get too wordy I have a simple theory
Joey three-foot theory if I can make
everybody happy
money enjoy their life
comes back to me I live life on a very
karmic way pay for karmic comeback right
simple theory very nice
I'm happy you made the [ __ ] trek up
in it's always a pleasure to see you
thank you for the dolls and stuff
do not forget [ __ ] Valentine's Day at
the San Jose improv and then the week
after that to 23rd I'm at the Treasure
Island and the 24th I'm at the Fox
Theatre in Tucson no other Tempe of
Phoenix appearances so if you live in
Arizona you're making the [ __ ] track
the Tucson I want to thank my man Bruce
Buffer again wait where's your website
Bruce Buffer calm for everything right
there and my podcast it's time you can
catch everything would that get released
we release every Thursday you know I've
done that podcast for 10 years now yeah
before even you and Joe started you know
that went back when they were kind of in
their infancy
well I is it is this this way for you
Joey it's a cathartic experience for me
when I'm done my podcast I feel like
I've released you know a lot of it's
tremendous again it's not about the
money no money but I'll cash that
paycheck
always always and the [ __ ] yes
sir the Man of Steel he'll be with me
Thursday night next week or this
tomorrow night it's my night tomorrow
night who Jimmy Comedy Store all right I
want to thank my man Bruce Buffer
I want to thank my men the [ __ ]
but most importantly I want to thank you
guys for listening don't forget the Fox
Theatre on the 23rd of February in
Tucson I'm not going to attempt Ian I'm
not going to Phoenix is my only Arizona
parents so gonna get your [ __ ]
skateboards and on the 22nd I'm at
Treasure Island Valentine's weekend
San Jose improv tickets are available
for Valentine's weekend the weekend
immense immense so get to live a day but
before we get out of there gonna talk to
you about something bigger right
everybody wants to know was gonna win
the big game is Tom Brady and Bill
Belichick gonna have another
championship to that Patriots dynasty or
the upstart Rams and the brilliant young
coach Shawn McBay be the last team
standing you tell me but remember one
thing before you tell me
that way you're better who you better
it's just as important as where you're
betting with that's why I tell people go
to my bookie not AG my bookie has been
in business for years the reputation is
rock-solid they do big cash bonuses so
off the bat you're making money for
doing nothing
you understand me and they have the
fastest payout in the business seriously
two business days now my bookie has
become the premier destinations for
props that's what the Super Bowl is all
about okay
these guys will truly let you bet on
anything whether it's a length on a
national anthem or the collar of the
sports drink bumped on the winning
coaches Edie my bookie has a buffet of
Patriot RAM props for you to chew on and
they also let you let let you live bet
the game who else does that nobody my
bookie so this weekend get ready Iraq
with a Super Bowl I only recommend
services that have been good to me
that's why I'm urging you to make your
way to my bookie why cuz you win they
pay join my bookie right now right now
as you're listening and they'll match
your deposit with a 50% bonus Joey what
are you talking about you give me a
yardstick I give you now you got 150 use
promo code Church to activate the offer
what you're gonna do is visit my bookie
dot AG today right now get your bank
started get your book started so Sunday
you could [ __ ] clean up all right
that's my bookie dot AG and use promo
code Church why because you play you win
and you get paid the church is also
sponsored by hims
I love this company you know why cuz
it's nice and easy 66 percent of man I
love men lose their hair by the age of
35 did you know that the thing is when
you start to notice hair loss it's too
late it's easier to keep the hair you
have then to replace the hair that you
lost that's where my hems comes in
that's where for hims dot-com comes in
I'm sorry for hems calm is a one-stop
shop for hair loss skin care and sexual
wellness for men you've been going on a
date with this girl lately the apparatus
ain't working
he's supposed to for hims calm has got
the answer to your problems let me tell
you how they do it for hims connects you
with real doctors and medical grade
solutions to treat your hair loss your
little star Ming Kia with well known
generic equivalents to name-brand
prescriptions to help you keep your hair
and also get that little worm hard down
there there's no snake or pills or gas
station counter supplements these are
prescription solutions backed by science
no waiting room no awkward person you
gotta talk to a doctor and tell them I
wanted a date and my thing ain't work
and nothing
you save hours by going to for hims calm
if you're like me listen you ain't got
much time you want to save time this is
the company that doesn't feel you're
losing your hair you listen take they're
there for you for hims calm what you do
is your answer a few quick questions the
doctor reviews it and they prescribe you
what your needs the products are shipped
directly to your door what I'm gonna do
for you right now is listen the church
family you gotta try all month two hymns
for five hours are you listening to me a
month trial month of hymns for five
hours while supplies last go to the
website for full details right now go to
four hymns calm and when you get there
you two get your five hours for the
month you got ass put in slash Joey so
go to four hymns dot-com slash Joey
again that's four hymns calm slash Joey
for hymns a real company that's gonna
help you out man you're losing your hair
stuff ain't working you don't want to
tell nobody this is the way to do it
alright I want to thank for hymns and I
want to thank my bookie I want to thank
on it I want to thank all our sponsors
to be honestly I love all you savages
from honored to zip recruiter square
square space I love all you guys but
anyway have a great weekend enjoy the
Superboy I want to thank the Flying Jew
I want to thank you guys for the bottom
my heart for being my family without you
guys we wouldn't even have a goddamn
show so listen enjoy the Superbowl enjoy
the families and enjoy yourselves thank
you very much for listening have a great
weekend
stay black see you [ __ ] Monday
morning take that [ __ ] meal II love
you guys